taking a live look now at the
intersection of Harmon Avenue and Las
Vegas Boulevard which is being
transformed into 63 Las Vegas a high
design retail complex so it's a flagship
restaurant has taken two years to design
it and then to build it the 20 million
dollar Ocean Prime restaurant we got an
exclusive tour just yesterday the only
TV station in town to walk the property
of Ocean Prime with the founder and CEO
of CMR Cameron Mitchell
it's been a labor of love and like I
said we're happy to be here we're
excited to be part of the Vegas fabric
here we go Cameron Mitchell grew up in
the restaurant business I have a dining
room right here it's the only job he's
ever known I would say Troubled Youth
and high school dropout and Runway and
then came home with Mom and and my dad
had cut off all the child support and
all that and uh and she could she
couldn't she was Administrative
Assistant she's been afford to give me
lunch money so I had to get a job so I
could have some spending money and lunch
money so I got a job at 265 an hour as a
dishwasher at 16. from dish room to
boardroom the founder and CEO of Cameron
Mitchell restaurants was named one of
the most influential and admired CEOs in
the country in 2022 and recipient of the
Lifetime Achievement Award we take care
of our people our people take care of
our guests and our guests take care of
our company by repeat visits we got this
exclusive tour with him behind the
scenes of what's being transformed into
his 18th Ocean Prime restaurant in Las
Vegas the 100th restaurant he's opened
since 1993. we want to be in Vegas for
about 10 years now we've been looking
all over and trying to find that right
location they found it at the corner of
Harmon and Las Vegas Boulevard
overlooking the strip it will be the
flagship restaurant of 63. nearly 15 000
square feet of dining space with a
rooftop Terrace the main bar sits out
against the backdrop of the Terrace and
then come out to the Terrace we've got
130 seats out here overlooking this trip
with all the action and activity but yet
still far enough away so your senses are
are stimulated but it's not overbearing
back inside guests will be greeted by a
cozy intimate Lounge a respite from the
strip and then the dining room will take
you to where land meets sea that's Ocean
Prime that's where our high-end
steakhouse and seafood restaurants and
um you know beautiful Raw Bar you know
wine cases I mean and the ceiling is uh
like a flowing ocean Reed slip from the
ceiling sparing no detail even the
ladies Lounge will be a destination
we've got complimentary champagne in
here last year you know it's uh it's
built to be a ladies Lounge in the
truest sense of the work so
um we joke that you know your guests may
not come back to the table for a few
more minutes and linger in here but
that's okay
the restaurant anticipates opening this
summer